in general dating sites are for guys who
don't have the gun to talk to a woman in
person I'm going to say you said no to
that right yeah that's correct I'm
correct no you're correct about my guess
you're trying to Inuit the answer by
like staring yeah uh yeah no that's
correct okay no I don't think look uh
uh what's that it's 2023 dating sites
are uh can be a really useful tool I
mean first of all I try not to I cannot
imagine being in the modern dating scene
it just must be a nightmare like I thank
God every day I'm not in it so I don't
want to sit here as a mar happily
married man and say well you shouldn't
be using that tool yeah um and probably
if you want to meet someone these days
like there's it's just it's it's
probably one of the only ways to do it
and going up and talking to someone
randomly is Rife with difficulty